this is a thing
happening to me and also to you Wow
TGI but GG IJ thank goodness it's Christ
don't bloated guys it is Monday you're
on its grace there's no rhyme or reason
coat supposed to be sexy Monday that's
right there is a rhyme and a reason for
today not so much a rhyme but a reason I
read on my tumblr and asked you guys
what did you want to talk about today
and so with that come out look homeless
when you wake up with greasy hair and
five minutes to get ready welcome to my
everyday though I don't have five
minutes to get ready I usually have like
a long time to get ready but I just wait
until the last five minutes so it's like
I only have five minutes to get ready
but at bat dude DAP that's the royalty
free version so today I decided I'll
give you my five-minute go to spring
look because it's spring and look
you're watching this right now let's get
started one of the first steps is to
analyze the state of your being what
does your hair feel like what do your
clothes feel and smell like are you
wearing sweat pants yes you are that's
great
all of this can be worked through with a
couple quick other steps let's do it
first step is to smell your person
what's it smell like you know thing that
you'd want other people to smelled great
then go into your side drawer and find
deodorant yes this is a very fun thing
that you just rub on your person in all
the crevices imagine it's like the
butter to your English muffin and there
and also there no one tells you to do it
there but you should the next look in my
spring look is making sure your feet are
covered so find the shoes that are
closest to you hey these our loafers
grandfather's never go out of style
so put them on your feet and then you
guess what have shoes on your feet
congratulations you did it here's the
overall look so far very sophisticated
color blocking it's in for this season
as well as not caring so god bless next
we're onto facial makeup look at all
these fun products I have I have a naked
2 palette a something blush and then an
airbrush foundation I don't know I
bought this on a whim I hate it but
maybe I don't and then a lip balm from a
company that is oh no don't smoke
ah what so first I'm going to do is put
this whoa airbrushed foundation that I
have never experienced before on my hand
and we are going to just pap smear it
all over the face imagine that your face
is a bagel
and that foundation is the cream cheese
get it all over it beautiful now it's
time for hair we are going to use our
hair straightener slash curling iron
that we bought in Toronto two and one
look how awesome that is and we're look
at it and realize that we don't need
that at all and we're going to put it to
the side and then pretend that our scalp
is a volcano that everyone around the
world wants to see your hair our torus
and your peak of your head is a volcano
that they need to see get them to the
top and then keep them there fence them
in and let them have a fun time look how
cultural is that last but not least
you're going to find a box that you have
on hand
for instance I have this box that I had
bought 48 rolls of toilet paper in and
you're just going to fit it to your
person oh oh my god oh how embarrassing
accessories I totally forgot about
accessories don't forget I have rings as
my accessories which I wear on a daily
basis that I think really bring out my
personality
I hope this helps
I don't know 48 rolls of toilet paper
was a great bargain highly recommend